Kim K male
nanny what's
this yo come on yo I already know how
you feel about oh come on bro do you
know the details on yeah she's like she
had a male nanny so there would be a
good male role model in Kanye's absence
for her son but a male nanny ain't a
good male role mod yeah why
not why not he's an entrepreneur bro
hardworking man entrepreneur taking care
of the kids yeah compassionate
empathetic yeah mhm I don't know man I'm
I'm with you real gender [__] problem
with
it you get to molest the kids what come
on what grown ass man wants to babysit
other people's kids unless they going to
molest them so that's only a job for
women take
babysitting yeah I'll hear him out I'll
hear him out you male babysitters caring
for kids this is a to be fair this is
not this is a grown ass
this is a grown ass man whose full-time
job is babysitting yeah you are crazy I
got to see he gets he gets to be around
Kim Kardashian and you know and all her
intimate settings and [__] like that
that's you know okay so he's he's in it
for the good Ambiance around no bro a
male babysitter you going to trust
around your children Al a male
babysitter I mean a female one killed
senena so it's so it's funny that she
just can't trust these no that was her
aunt
no that was just like the work of [__]
no no no no no she like handled she was
like heavily involved in their their
thing I think okay but it wasn't her
aunt oh wasn't her aunt yo point is no
it wasn't her aunt but she was like a
super fan that like got to work with
them and work her way up but it's also
funny that she's just so bad at having a
relationship with like a male who's a
healthy role model she's like why don't
I just hire somebody try not to [__]
them and then maybe they a
male May is that him I don't know bro I
got that's him oh that's a problem no
that's a football player right I think
he's a black dude you just saw a black
guy in a [__] Jersey and you assume
that he played for the team uh yeah and
when I do that it's racist when I do
that at the airport every single time
he's the tallest one with the Jersey up
bro yeah I I don't know I don't know so
who can be a babysitter women okay
Jamaicans lesbian Jamaican lesbian I was
raised by lesbians Latino women I was
raised by Colombian lesbian I can tell
BR that's why you dress like that that's
it I'm a Columbian lesbian did she just
leave you at the park no that was the
white [__] oh my my my mom hired this
Irish [__] never again cuz she left me
in the [__] seat lazy
[__] all right then the Colombian lesos
got on it and it was fire oh she was a
lesbian I had a Colombian lesbian used
to cook me a rice and tuna you know she
like that
tuna rice and tuna every single day but
I'm yeah male babysitter no I had a male
babysitter once and I had to sit down
with my parents after that [__] I was
like what are we doing
yo i s I sat them down he left the door
closed I said yo sit down what are we
doing yo y trying to get Meck y' try if
I didn't have my OS bagos it would have
been on it was too difficult to unsnap
the shoulders I was luckily in my
ashkash
BOS apparently Kanye has been cool with
him wait but why female babysitter is
going to [__] the kids they not going to
[__] them why and if they are that's
what think it's less it's less you just
yeah it's a head start it's less
it's less do we know where gizan Maxwell
is right now it's less I'm just saying
it's less she's still alive Street a
safe is is that the guy I don't know who
it is bro we got we got to get him on
the Pod we immediately need him on the
podt nah bro hey yo seen that
before
yeah also you sign up at price.com and
use the promo code Schultz they will
match your initial deposit up to $100
yeah